monsieur le ministre hier soir en
écoutant les annonces de madame la
Première ministre j'ai pensé à des amis
des connaissances Isabelle Jean-Marc
Philippe la première travaille dans
l'agroalimentaire depuis 40 ans et elle
devait prendre sa retraite à 62 ans elle
devra travailler un an et trois mois de
plus le deuxième il est charpentier il
entre dans le dispositif carrière longue
mais qui sera repoussé et donc il devra
travailler plusieurs mois de plus le
troisième veine de perdre son emploi à
60 ans peu d'espoir d'en retrouver un et
une durée d'indemnisation du chômage que
vous venez généreusement de réduire et
la perspective d'un meilleur revenu
produit par la retraite qui s'éloigne
vous allez faire payer votre réforme
idéologique parce ceux qui travaillent
depuis longtemps déjà qui cotise depuis
longtemps déjà et qui ont les métiers
les plus difficiles et les moins bien
rémunérés et par les précaires et dans
le même temps vous ne demandez aucune
contrepartie aux employeurs vous refusez
obstinément de mobiliser les gains
parfois faramineux engrangé par atteint
depuis quelques mois alors monsieur le
ministre vous qui ne cessez de mettre en
avant la valeur travail pourquoi
maltraitez-vous à ce point les
travailleurs
[Applaudissements]
du fait d'emploi de l'insertion monsieur
dupes
madame la sénatrice pardonnez-moi la
réforme est nécessaire j'ai évoqué la
raison pour laquelle il fallait la faire
pour sauver le système par répartition
j'ai aussi dit qu'il fallait faire avec
le plus de justice possible il y a deux
éléments qui répondent très précisément
à votre question le premier élément
c'est que nous avons dans le cadre de la
concertation que j'ai mené depuis
plusieurs mois travailler avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux tous
les partenaires sociaux tous les
syndicats toutes les organisations
patronales et avec les groupes
politiques que nous avons consulté et
nous avons nous avons abouti nous avons
abouti sur un certain nombre de
convergences ça n'efface pas les
désaccords sur l'âge mais il y a des
convergences sur la question de la
pénibilité nous modifions contre le
compte de personnel de prévention avec
l'ensemble des secrétaires pour en
faciliter l'acquisition des points nous
créons la possibilité d'un véritable
congé de reconversion nous faisons en
sorte de mieux protéger ceux qui
travaillent de nuit en équipe postée
nous allons retravailler sur la question
des ports de charge des postures
pénibles
la délibérations pour faire en sorte que
les accords de prévention soit là et
c'est un milliard d'euros sur cinq ans
qui seront consacrés au financement de
la prévention tout en renforçant la
possibilité de partir de manière
anticipée dans ce cas d'un suivi médical
renforcé sur les carrières longues vous
l'avez évoqué nous maintenons évidemment
et bien évidemment le départ à 58 ans
pour tous ceux qui ont cotisé 5
trimestres pendant 16 ans nous
maintenons le dispositif existant celui
qui permet de partir avec deux ans
d'avance pour ceux qui ont cotisé 5
trimestres avant 20 ans et nous créons
un nouveau dispositif qui va s'appliquer
très certainement à ceux que vous avez
évoqué pour que ceux qui ont concrétisé
5 trimestres avant 18 ans et je pense
tout particulièrement apprentis que ceci
puisse partir avec quatre ans d'avance
et à 60 ans sans qu'il y ait bouger
d'âge pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler le plus tôt la vérité madame
la sénatrice elle est peut-être sur deux
points le premier c'est que les exemples
que vous avez cités les amis que vous
avez auquel vous avez pensé je souhaite
pour vous que ce soit des amis
imaginaires parce que le principal
bouger le principal décalage de la rage
de départ c'est la hausse de la durée de
cotisation vous avez voté en 2013 et la
deuxième chose que je vais vous dire
c'est quand vous écoutant et je j'ai en
tête les propos du responsable du parti
socialiste qui s'est converti à la
doctrine de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous avez
ainsi perdu le sens de la raison et la
responsabilité
madame
monsieur le ministre qu'il est doux à
mes oreilles de vous de me faire des
remarques à moi sur ce qu'a fait ma
famille politique et ce que nous avons
voté quand ça vient de vous monsieur le
ministre vous et moi savons très bien
j'ai quelques souvenirs monsieur le
ministre dans le département des Landes
avec un de mes grands anciens qui
s'appelait Henry Emmanuelli et que vous
aimiez beaucoup à l'époque de vous
appréciez beaucoup à l'époque voilà donc
il fallait pas me tenter monsieur le
ministre le corps le corps dit que la
part des retraites dans le pays B c'est
14 % que ça ne bouge pas et que donc le
système n'est pas en danger les critères
de pénibilité que vous venez de donner
c'est vous qui les avez enlevés en 2018
quand vous êtes arrivés au gouvernement
et vous pouvez le traduire comme vous
voulez monsieur le ministre mais cette
réforme vous la faites uniquement payer
par les salariés et par les plus
modestes des salariés et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure des réactions quand je
citais mes amis qui ne sont pas
imaginaires croyez-le j'ai entendu oh oh
mais quand on a travaillé 42 ans et
qu'on demande de travailler un an de
plus c'est un an de trop
la